à montréal des centaines de surfer et de
kayakistes profite du fleuve mais il ya
des jours ne pas avaler d'où j'ai un nul
est donc de trois jours après la grosse
pluie juste après après avoir fini 30 à
la maison puis voilà la gastro
que mon nez dans le canal d'un rejet de
la surverse un tiers ce canal l'eau se
déverse dans le fleuve saint laurent
quand il y à des fortes pluies quand ils
l'intercepteur dégoût le méga égouts qui
entoure le mot real est trop plein d'eau
alors la surverse se déverse dans
l'ouvragé en pierre dans le pré sal ar
donc ces eaux ne passe pas par l' usine
d'épuration avant de se retrouver dans
le fleuve le canal saint pierre est
située juste à côté du pont de
l'île-des-soeurs
les gens du coin l'appelle la bd capote
des données obtenues par la loi sur
l'accès à l'information indiquent que
cet ouvrage où circulent 10% de toutes
les eaux d'égouts de montréal a débordé
33 fois en 2013
parfois pendant plus de trois heures on
est dans une situation autour ans dans
le même tuyau des camps se tue au débat
sur les formes ses tics les rejets de
pitau des rejets d'entreprise et les
rejettent des domiciles tout est
déversée dans cette structure là vers le
ferez sonara alors où montréal étudie
plusieurs projets de plage
personne ne parle des débordements
d'égouts qui surviennent dans les 150
tuyaux qui ceinturent lille
mais les surfeurs les kayakistes d'eau
vivent eux sont bien au courant du
problème les eaux d'égout déversés au
canal saint pierre suivent les berges
d'un fort courant et se retrouve en une
vingtaine de minutes dans la vague
derrière habitat 67
est ce que vous voyez quand même que la
qualité de l'eau est moins bonne avait
vous déjà remarqué quand il pleut que ça
change ça change beaucoup ont les ans
laissant en mai laissant des fois c'est
pas juste la couleur c'est l'odeur ça
sans quoi on parle et la barre il faut
vers les pays seulement à lasalle et
verdun on compte une trentaine de tuyaux
comme celui ci certains juste en amont
des plages proposer les surfeurs ne
comprennent pas pourquoi la ville de
montréal ne les avertit pas des
déversements majeur dans le fleuve
nous avons pourtant appris que la ville
informe parcs canada des déversements
dans le canal lachine la location de
kayaks et de pédalos est ensuite
interdite pour 72 heures je pense que
beaucoup plus de monde qui vient dans la
loire une journée ici qu une journée
dans canal la chaîne sage et aucun doute
fac pas ce serait très bien qu'on soit
informé
la ville est bien consciente du problème
et prévoit la construction de plusieurs
réservoirs souterrains pour accumuler
l'eau en temps de pluie et éliminer les
déversement d'égoûts dans le fleuve on a
des objectifs pour les dix prochaines
années
86 milliards d'investissements pour une
maison neuve pour nous au rattrapage à
faire
il ya déjà eu des décennies ou ignorent
presque rien
en compagnie de daniel green qui
surveille le fleuve depuis des décennies
nous sommes partis à la recherche d'un
déversement d'eaux traitées mais
pourtant fortement contaminée par des
bactéries des virus des parasites et des
produits pharmaceutiques et la recherche
le bouillon
à la senteur on est littéralement au
dessus je point de rejet d'une
population de 1.4 million de personnes
alors tous les os non désinfectée sera
jette ici
maintenant on le sent on est vraiment
sur un point
probablement un des points les plus
polluées au niveau des coliformes fécaux
des voies de bus poilu au canada une
usine d'épuration de montréal l'une des
plus grandes au monde déverse ses eaux
non désinfectée alé lô vaches juste en
aval des îles de boucherville
l'équivalent du volume d'un stade
olympique plein est rejetée au fleuve en
temps sec et trois fois plus lors des
fortes
l'échantillon prélevé par daniel göring
contient 480000 un colis par 100
millilitres soit 2400 x la limite
acceptable pour la baignade
si j'avais ma place dos la probabilité
que j'ai pas de gastro soi est très
faible
parce que les concentrations sont
incroyables ici alors c'est un danger
public de tomber à l'eau ici et c'est un
danger public de tomber à l'eau à 40
kilomètres d'ici dans le panache de
pollution la ville de montréal
selon le ministère de l'environnement du
québec les eaux usées non désinfectée de
montréal et de longueuil en pêche la
baignade jusque dans le delta des îles
de sorel vais depuis les années 1930 des
plages publiques assez importante et
même les gens de l'est de casino pour
pour justement bénéficier de ces espaces
publics là en janvier 2008 le maire
tremblay annoncé en grande pompe la mise
en fonction d'une usine de désinfection
à l'ozone pour 2012 six ans plus tard
l'appel d'offres pour l'élaboration des
plans n'a pas encore été fait on nous le
promet maintenant pour l'automne il ya
eu aussi on se rappellera certaines
petites problème avec cette ancienne
administration notamment les compteurs
d'eau de le grand scandale ce qui aurait
nantis énormément tous les grands
projets qui qui pouvait avoir lieu à
montréal
je trouve ça dommage que complice pour
qu'on puisse pas éventuellement en
arriver à solutionner ce problème là bas
ces problèmes et équitable pour
l'ensemble des populations
une épuration à moitié c'est quasiment
comme pas divulgation du tout quand
c'est contre encore pas utiliser l'eau
alors pour éviter d'avoir perdu un point
4 milliards de dollars dans libération
les autres montréal
il faut investir pour finir le travail
faire de sorte que la ville de montréal
arrête d'être des plus grands pollueurs
du québec